ici en salle des conférences 20 juillet
bonjour bonjour sénateurs rattaché au
groupe socialiste ici au sénat vous êtes
élue à paris on a entendu et
effectivement le président du conseil
scientifique dire que nous ne sommes pas
au bout de la vague je cite que nous
sommes dans la vague et que pour prendre
des décisions de levée des restrictions
les marqueurs ne sont plus les chiffres
de la contamination mais ses impacts sur
le système de soins c'est ça maintenant
qu'il faut regarder pour savoir ce qui
va se passer dans l'épidémie bas d'abord
j'ai à dire c'est un peu un aveu ce
qu'on dit depuis longtemps c'est que le
pass sanitaires ou vaccinale n'a aucun
impact sur la vague au micro il ne
change rien à la circulation du virus
donc effectivement jean françois
delfraissy a raison les indicateurs de
circulation virus centrale et les
contaminations ça n'a plus de sens ça
n'a plus de sens et ça n'est pas le pas
de vaccinale qui change quoi que ce soit
le deuxième point c'est est ce que le
pass vaccinale a un effet sur la
vaccination et il a épuisé complètement
comme nous l'avions constaté cet effet
sur la vaccination ces derniers jours on
était à 13000 primo vacciner à peu près
la dernière chose c'est les indicateurs
de saturation du système hospitalier et
là il est beaucoup trop tôt pour dire
quoi que ce soit puisqu'on est toujours
à des niveaux de contamination élevé
même si au micron génère moins de
saturation des services de soins on a
plus de 30000 personnes hospitalisées
aujourd'hui dans notre pays oui je
m'arrête un instant sur ce que vous
venez de dire concernant la vaccination
parce qu'on sait le groupe socialiste a
milité en faveur de l'obligation
vaccinale et on a compris dans les
auditions de cette semaine que il y
avait eu un effet au nom de l' annonce
de ce pass vaccinale au mois de décembre
avec des prix au vaccinez vous le dit
maintenant les faits il est complètement
arrêtée il y en a plus cet effet sur les
annonces ça ne sert plus à rien coûté
c'était écrit venir il faut avoir un
petit peu de mémoire en juillet dernier
on avait constaté que l'annoncent par le
chef de l'état avait entraîné vous vous
rappelez de ruée vers la vaccination
donc le fait d'annoncer entraîne ce
phénomène là et quand le 10 janvier
olivier ferrand a été auditionné ici au
sénat je lui ai posé cette question je
lui ai fait cette remarque il a il a nié
en disant qu' il y avait un effet
important il ya toujours un effet
quelques jours s'est terminée le pass
vaccinale n'est pas actuellement un
outil adapté à la gestion de l'épidémie
alors quand faut-il le lever c'est toute
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui on a
évoqué avec jean procès récit
effectivement ce nom d'hospitalisation
les service de réa qui sont toujours
saturé et que c'est donc ces chiffres en
baisse qui pourrait bien faire la levée
des restrictions
hier et bien la misa santé sur bfm a dit
on ne sait que le pass vaccinale aura
une fin et il est presque cinq cents
soit avant début juillet il évoque donc
une anticipation par rapport à la du 31
juillet c'est une bonne nouvelle ça
toutes les auditions qui ont été menées
ces derniers temps montrent la même
chose c'est encore une fois je vais me
répéter le pass vaccinale n'est pas un
bon outil de gestion de l'actuelle vague
épidémique est donc c'est un outil
politique choisir le pass vaccinale
plutôt que l'obligation vaccinale avec
la mise en oeuvre de politiques de
conviction et de contraintes les deux à
la fois c'est un choix politique on
entre donc la levée sera déterminée par
des raisons politiques je pense que dans
les semaines à venir et en tout cas
avant l'élection présidentielle
le gouvernement utilisera la levée du
pass vaccinale comme un outil politique
et non comme un outil de gestion de la
crise sanitaire est donc aussi comme un
outil de campagne électorale vous dites
c'est un argument électoraliste que
lever les restrictions au moment de
l'entrée en campagne parce que le choix
sera fait dans les semaines à venir et
nous verrons bien on peut donner rendez
vous dans quelques semaines mais de
levée du dispositif du pass vaccinale
mais ce n'est pas une forme de cynisme
dans ces cas là de la part de l'exécutif
nous avons dit que lorsque olivier
ferrand notamment à parler de
l'obligation déguisé il y avait un mode
de gestion de la crise sanitaire qui
n'était ni transparent ni claire ni
franc avec les français on est toujours
dans le même sillon on l'a vu sur la
gestion de la crise dans les écoles avec
ce pilotage totalement chaotique et on
le voit avec cette question du pass
vaccinale qui est une façon d'utiliser
la crise sanitaire à des fins politiques
et je vais ajouter un point comme
actuellement les instances scientifiques
sont utilisés à des fins politiques par
le gouvernement
[Musique]